you're a babysitter what's that like
five boxes try 20 double-time on honey
adventures in babysitting is a reimagine
take on the 80s classic I'm desperate
for a babysitter of course I was a big
fan of the original movie so to be able
to be a part of the new version is an
honor
where are you answering my phone the
babysitter's own babysitter our parents
and their generation of this thumb so
much and are probably so excited to
share it with their kids babies even
rule number one never take your eyes off
the kids ever this version of
introducing is unique because instead of
one baby sir there's two rival
babysitters Jenny and Lola GUI to a
concerts awesome
how could you let a 14 grandkids leak
out into the city they're polar
opposites in every sense of the word
which leads them to this incredible
adventure
fans of the ocean we are going to love
the fact that there's still nods to the
original like Jenny Scout is a camel
coat like I was of a shoe so as well
you've got a J's Chi was slicked who her
hero in this roller derby star you
you're my hero in the original movie you
know Sarah's was Thor I would say one of
my favorite scenes from the original
ones the blues jam session I was very
excited to see how they updating for our
new generation I think they're going to
love our new version just as great a
babysitter as you may think through all
these reimagined TV shows and movies
based on classic running from the past
version for this new generation I think
there's a lot of changes since the
eighties Educare to the audience that is
growing up now I think they're going to
quite the adventure your piece you're
never going to ask me babysit again if
they do I dust for 10 bucks more an hour